Ned fatty which one are you talking to  Stan it is fatty Stewart thinking would  you leave okay we're good Kamel how do  we fix axe face there  well I was born this way I mean there's  not much it  the first flower Roy Leslie Chow stole  21 million dollars from me on a Tuesday  if we could actually do this on a  Tuesday it might be better there damn it  by one more acting with a tape piece of  tape  well yeah all right nope no it's  actually much easier for me yeah yeah  good unreal all right that was super  very fun is our first blueprint right no  you had plenty exactly why by signing on  pensive yeah where'd you learn that word  words with friends what friends Ellen  Marcus 54 wheezy Joe cat lover Sheila  and Penn State Jerri what up  excuse me about a cop I'm just in town  well I've got to make some changes in my  life and this is one of them Adhan are  we breaking up like it says on my  facebook profile is complicated